Nhật ngất, nói hòa của hỏi không chỉ quyết định đúng mà phải quyết định chúng của kìa thầy.
Bại trọng một quyết xách có thể làm lỡ một thời g lonely chứ lợt.
Các quên đẹp về kích đế xả hỏi ngân sách nhà nước, lầu thức công, các trương trình lục điều của vâng
cắt dự án quan trọng của vâng điều là những quyết xách lớn, gắn vừa lấy cân mạng lâu dài của các vâng
xin tọng, phải được xem xác toàn viện qua học thật trọng những đợi không được
xích chậm chế trở thành điểm ngàn của phát triển.
Trong điều kiện một lực quan hạnh chế của khỏi càng phy nứng cao chất lợt phần tích xí xách.
Năng lực dự báo chứ lợt của đánh giá tắt đầu, phải chọn đúng việc lớn,
đúng không đợi phá, đúng không chỉnh trọng đợi đúng linh vực thành chốt để tập trung một lực,
không rằng trại mấy nút chia đều.